help the dolly parton break a big record  this week what what a career moment I  know it was unbelievable she is such a  legend and she's so kind Scott Hoying  Mitch Brasi and their pentatonics  bandmates helped a Dolly Parton become  the first ever artist to land a top 20  hit on Billboard's Hot Country Songs  chart in each decade since the 1960s  this week with vari make of her classic  Jolene pentatonic such an honor to work  with you guys and we were just like  melted to the floor cuz we're all huge  fans  dolly giving you any advice guided you  at all we also have another Christmas  album coming out correct what can we  expect from this one signature  pentatonix jolliness  definitely we got really creative with  some so I am very proud of this one  especially a couple of the tracks that  people are my favorite Christmas music  we've ever made and there's two  originals of this book